but the intuition is that
knowing these five construct quantities
is going to tell me a bit about what my
prediction should be
and so it's kind of free information
that i get to know
hello there today we'll look at neuter
networks meta learning useful conserved
quantities by ferran alett and dylan
doblar and others this is another one of
the with the authors installations
videos whatever where i just discuss the
paper briefly right now and then we'll
jump into an interview with one of the
first authors with feron and we'll go
through the paper together and i think
feron can explain this so much better
than i can and i'm also able to ask some
of my dumb questions so this was a lot
of fun and i definitely invite you to
stick around if you already know a
little bit what the paper is about feel
free to skip ahead
if you don't know what the paper is
about the paper essentially deals with
neural networks that predict dynamical
systems and
uh in these dynamical systems very often
there are these conserved quantities
that are part of it for example in a
physical system energy is conserved
momentum is conserved and things like
this
and under this constraint you can build
in this constraint into the predictive
neural network so that the neural
network does a better job
and they build these neutral networks in
order to dynamically learn these
conserved quantities and then adjust at
run time during forward propagation
tailor the loss to conserve these
quantities and i think that's really
cool it's different and yeah that's what
i like about it so pretty brief
introduction this paper obviously is
named after neuter's theorem which
essentially they say here loosely states
the following for every continuous
symmetry property of a dynamical system
there is a corresponding quantity whose
value is conserved in time
for example
they say a system of planets interacting
via gravity the system is translation
invariant in all three cardinal
directions notre's theorem asserts that
there must be a conserved quantity for
each of these symmetries in this case
linear momentum is conserved so the
symmetry in space as translations
is accompanied by a conserved quantity
which is linear momentum now we don't
always obviously know these quantities
and
they're not always super explicit and
they're not always exact so what we are
going to be dealing with here is
predictions of dynamical systems and the
example here is the prediction of video
of like a physical interaction so this
is
a thing here on an inclined plane it
sort of slides down
and then collides with this other thing
right here and the goal is to predict
the next frames of this video now we
could just build a neural network to
just to predict these things uh frame by
frame by frame and that would
go certainly well if we had a lot of
data however if we don't have a lot of
data what we need to do is we need to
build in
inductive biases and
the inductive biases what people usually
do is they build in these symmetries
directly for example they build in the
physical laws they know how the world
works and they say you know whether i
translate it to the left or to the right
it doesn't really matter and so on but
building in these symmetries and i think
we know this from geometric
deep learning building in these
symmetries is very powerful but it can
also be cumbersome because you have to
define them beforehand
this paper goes ahead and says you know
what's real what's a lot easier than
building in symmetries directly is
building in a constraint to conserve a
given quantity and that is a lot easier
and there's a potential that you can
actually learn it from data and with
neutral's theorem we know that the two
things are equivalent so if a system
conserves a quantity it essentially
encodes a symmetry in the system
so what do we do this is the very high
level overview over these networks we
take so this entire thing here is one
forward propagation
uh we take
the original frame
we put it through a forward predicting
neural network which is this f theta
right here this is a network that simply
forward predicts frames as we i i said
initially uh so we forward predict
forward predict forward predict this
gives us an initial set of of outputs
right here these x tilde now these are
going to be pretty pretty bad uh not
pretty bad but um
if we don't have a lot of data to learn
from
these we don't expect them to be
particularly good and that's the regime
we are here
what we do then is we're trying to
adjust this f thing right here
um
in the moment so during the forward
propagation we're going to update our
predicting neural network by this
neutral loss so we're going to do an
update
a temporary update to the weights of the
f network
and we're going to do this into
direction of this neutral loss so you
can see here we have these networks g
lying around and g is always the same
network so what we're going to do is
we're going to feed each frame that we
predicted through g
and
g always being the same network it will
output the same thing and now obviously
um
if you know given given that how
i made this introduction you might
already have guessed that g
is the part that predicts the quantity
to be preserved
so
what we want to do is we want to put all
these things through g
and then we want to
these these will give us a bunch of
outputs right g here and here and here
and here will output some things and the
things can either be a number or an
entire vector right an embedding vector
so essentially g takes this
thing right here it actually takes two
consecutive frames and embeds it into
some space
and now ideally all these g's would
output the same thing
which would mean that we have conserved
some quantity and therefore encoded some
symmetry however
initially these g's are not going to
output the same thing so we are going to
attempt to change the f function such
that the g's output
more the same thing there is a loss
involved right here
this is the neutral loss they call it
and it is defined down here
so you can see
all this really is is it's either
defined in one of two ways either you
take the difference between the g
function of the initial frame and the
frame at time point t
or and you calculate the difference or
you calculate the difference between
consecutive frames in either way since
you sum across all the frames this means
that all the outputs of the g network
will should approximately be the same
now what do you do with this information
again we're still we're still doing one
forward propagation
so what do you do with this information
you calculate this neuter loss which is
one we just described and then sorry for
skipping around so much
you're going to do one update step so
these are the parameters of the f
network we're going to do one update
step into the direction of the gradient
and it's the direction of the gradient
with respect to the parameters of the f
network
so this is the forward predicting
network so essentially we are
saying how do i need to update
my forward predicting network
such that right such that the frames
that it outputs the frames that it
predicts in the future
make it such that the g functions of all
of these frames are more similar to each
other or more similar to the g function
of that first frame right so we're going
to in time update the f function right
here and after that we're going to
forward forward propagate again with
this new f function and thereby obtain
our final prediction this is one this is
like an inner optimization that we do
during forward propagation i find this
to be pretty cool now they just do they
just do one gradient step obviously uh
otherwise you know you could do a lot of
things and you could like program in
atom and add a graph not only
one like gradient
step which is one sgd step essentially
um but even with one step that is good
enough
so again
they here is the entire training
procedure in an algorithm you can see
that um
let's start down here they start with
randomly initialized weights these
weights here are for the g network these
weights are for the f network
they sample batches for each batch they
predict the sequence now the sequence
prediction is this entire thing we just
looked at so the sequence prediction is
i'm going to start at the initial frames
i'm going to use the the f the original
f the one i currently have
unconditional let's say to forward
predict all of the frames once then i'm
going to put
all of these predictions here into this
neutral loss i'm going to calculate the
gradient how do i need to update this f
for this particular data point to make
the g functions output the
more similar things i'm going to attain
new parameters again these are just
temporary parameters i'm going to use
these temporary parameters here to do
another round of forward prediction
which gives me my final estimate i could
probably repeat this again
and or i could do multiple steps right
here i could probably do a lot of things
but this is sort of the simplest case
and then i will return these what do i
do with them
you can see right here this is my output
now i'm going to input these things into
what's called the task loss and the task
loss in our case here is just the video
prediction loss so that's going to be
some l2 distance between the frames
i output and the frames that actually so
these are the output frames these are
the frames that are actually in the
video
and then i'm going to just run back prop
on that so
update the parameters of both g and f on
the task loss so what does it mean
g is going to be updated
such that if i do this whole sequence
again um
if i do the whole sequence of predicting
then tailoring my loss 2g right i tailor
my loss to the g function
g is going to be updated such that next
time
if i tailor my loss to it it's going to
lead to a better outcome overall
and f
is going to be updated similarly it's
going to be updated such that
well next time
if i do this whole procedure of first
predicting these which i'm going to use
the parameters then updating the
parameters and then um so then updating
the parameters using g and then
predicting again
i update my f such that this whole
procedure uh will result in a better
loss now this is a i think this is the
magic of of our back propagation
frameworks that we can even think of
these types of things because i mean
behold actually writing this down and
implementing the back backwards pass
here yourself that'd be crazy
so this is the entire the entire
algorithm right here
now again given that there are you know
as you can see some hyper parameters
here such as the learning rates uh they
only do one gradient step as we as we
mentioned so this isn't an exact
enforcement of that constraint right
this is only an approximate enforcement
essentially essentially the only
condition the only additional constraint
that we introduce here is this
requirement that the g function is the
same g function on all the forward
predicted things and that is our
knowledge that we are dealing with a
dynamical system and in this dynamical
system some quantities should be
preserved the way we build the losses
means that g can simply output
a constant value otherwise it would not
be useful to the loss right
but also the way we build the loss means
that it is not an exact constraint like
we would build this into the
architecture that a quantity must be
conserved so it's able to deal with you
know real world data such as this video
where even sometimes like a hand may
come in there's friction and so on it's
not an exactly conserving system right
and the way we do this in the moment in
the forward pass update using this
neutral loss that means that i can now
tailor whatever like i can i can tailor
the inductive bias for this particular
sample so i can learn it's kind of meta
learning thing right what i learn is how
to in the moment adjust my loss function
uh to this particular sample of data
now as i said obviously if you had more
data and all
maybe you wouldn't need this but it does
help a lot in their experiments in the
in these regimes where you do not have a
lot of data they have a theoretical
section right here where they uh have a
reduced case and show that it can be
useful to impose these constraints
then they have a bunch of experimental
settings among other things they also
they don't only do
what i just said with the video
prediction but they also do a
prediction where they don't not
everything is a neural network so where
the things they predict are actual
physical quantities and they do it using
symbolic regression and this is the same
method except it's not neural networks
it's symbolic regression and what that
does is
it comes up with these equations for
example for the ideal pendulum as you
can see these equations are insanely
close like they recover the correct
equations and these are symbolic
regressions uh so the it's not you don't
you didn't only have to
come up with the number right here you
actually the network had to come up not
the network the system had to come up
with the entire equation given some
basic building blocks of variables and
you can square stuff and you can take
the cosine of stuff
so these experiments show that the
method can indeed recover physical
quantities that are conserved if you
present them with a scenario where this
is the case and they use either ideal
scenarios so ideal data generation but
they also use real world data from
pendulums where obviously you have
energy dissipating and then
you can you can compare so here uh i i
believe they do compare with what they
say is a baseline so as that predicts
into the future uh the longer prediction
they do
the worse that gets
or
i guess the losses over here you can see
that
but then also the hamiltonian neural
networks which enforce exact constraints
uh they enforce the quantities to be
preserved exactly if you face them with
real world data you can see right here
the quantities aren't changed at all yet
the loss still goes up because the
quantity isn't actually conserved in the
real data and the
neuter networks do follow the ground
truth data much more closely because
they can model also
inexact constraints and
not not
super strict enforcement of these
constraints which is what i think we
need in real world data
they do a bunch of other experiments
especially as i said also a video
prediction where they do outperform uh
various baselines they investigate uh
where the network pays attention to and
whether or not you can actually
uh
move or do a lot more inner iteration
steps than just one because we just did
one in our iteration steps there there
is no
reason why this should remain at one and
here they show that even though they
only trained with one at inference time
they can actually take a bunch more and
the outer loss will still go down
so this it all validates a little bit of
the reasoning behind the method
yeah i don't want to take up too much of
your time right here because i want to
jump into the interview i let me know
what you think of these immor
interviewee style paper reviews i quite
enjoyed the interview and i do think um
it's pretty useful to have the authors
there because they
they can correct me
pretty instantly all right see you over
there
okay cool hi everyone uh today i have
with me feron alette who is one of the
primary authors of the neuter networks
paper and here to discuss with us
probably a little bit about the
intrinsics of the paper and maybe also
for me personally because the paper is
very technical it's a new field for me
as well connecting physics to machine
learning building all of this into
neural networks there's also a bit of
symbolic regression in there
so i feel a lot of things are coming
together here i found the paper pretty
cool and it's new and that's what's
interesting so feron thank you very much
for being here yeah thanks for the
invitation wonderful to be here
thanks um so your your paper uh deals
with do you call it neuter networks
nether networks how do you even how do
you pronounce i brought in other
networks but i think
i'm not
german
so i'm not sure i'm pronouncing it
properly i'm not a german either but but
i i think that uh the author was called
what's called neuter yeah yeah so you're
pronouncing it more properly than him
maybe but essentially could you give us
maybe just first an insight where does
the name because the name is kind of
distinct right because there is the
neuter theorem yeah what does the
theorem say in general yeah so the
another theorem was kind of the
inspiration for for for our work and the
intuition is that uh for every symmetry
of a dynamical system there is a certain
conservation law that that's going to uh
apply to that system uh so for instance
imagine uh your you have a planetary
system of planets moving around
the physics laws don't change from today
to tomorrow that means that there's a
time symmetry of the system and here uh
another theorem tells you oh
if that if there is a symmetry here that
means that there must be a quantity
that's conserved uh over time and in
this case uh
um for time symmetry there is energy
that's being conserved um so we use that
as a motivation not that the technical
details more like the higher level
message of of the of the theorem uh to
uh build a new machine learning model
and the intuition is that in machine
learning symmetries are one of the core
ways in which we've improved data
efficiency and model
and so it would be very cool if we could
kind of automatically learn some of
these symmetries
um
but uh symmetries are kind of hard to
quantify and and get a hold of uh
computationally and the intuition is
that um
they talk about kind of counterfactuals
and kind of global in the sense that
when i was telling you about this time
symmetry i was saying if i were to look
at the planetary system tomorrow the
laws of physics would be the same but i
don't have access to the data for
tomorrow uh it's a kind of
counterfactual so uh the model cannot
handle this instead
conserved quantities can be directly
measured i can check oh this quantity
which i will call energy is being
conserved on my actual data
and that makes it very easy to uh
to quantify
yeah we've heard in i think in the
recent past even a lot of people
attempting to get more out of symmetries
out of neural network with i'm thinking
of i'm thinking of like
group convolutional neural networks and
so on that try to actively build in
symmetries into neural networks but
it seems like they can only do that in
situations where they know the symmetry
that will appear they already know a
molecule doesn't matter which way i look
at it right so i can directly build that
in but your reasoning is that because
assessing conserved quantities is an
easier task than assessing symmetries it
might be possible to learn the conserved
quantities
dynamically actually learn them from
data is that approximately correct yes
exactly exactly um so
and the and the the theorem uh is the
motivation because it tells us that
conserved quantities are kind of on the
same level of of powerful as as
symmetries four dynamical systems in
particular uh if we're doing image
classification that does not apply
because image classification is not a
dynamical system um
but that's the intuition yes
and you you even have some some slack in
there you discuss uh you know we can
we it doesn't even have to be absolutely
conserved quantity it doesn't have to be
an absolute symmetry that we deal with
by learning it from data we can even
handle approximate symmetries is that
yeah right
that's a another thing that may be a bit
different from our work than other works
which is that um
some symmetries are only approximately
conserved or conserved quantities are
only approximately conserved so for
instance you if you have a dissipative
system like uh in the real world there
is friction and so you actually lose
energy if you don't cons if you don't
consider the entire system uh you you
usually have small losses uh so in this
case you would say you would like to say
oh energy is conserved but not quite so
it's fine if you if your prediction
doesn't fully conserve energy but
knowing about energy conservation maybe
helps you uh with the overall prediction
and maybe i want to i want to get to
sort of a little bit of an example of
where so people can imagine this a
little bit more now i only have a mouse
here because i forgot the ipad because
i'm stupid but maybe we can give the
small example of a pendulum right so
here's a pendulum it hangs here and it
sort of gets down here and here is the
little ball and the pendulum is
accurately described by i think the
angle right here that it's sort of off
the of the main axis and also its
momentum let's say it swings in this
direction with a certain with a certain
uh speed and this describes the pendulum
now your model focuses on predicting
the future let's say or at least from
from what i can tell so what your model
would be able to do is it would be able
to predict the next time step right here
right then it's a bit here here
sorry it's it's a little bit more up to
the left right
so it's a little bit more up and then
it's it's even more up over here and
then it swings back and so on it swings
back over now
can you explain to us what are sort of
the what is the symmetry here and what
are the conserved quantities yeah so in
this case uh for the pendulum we know
that if we were to swing the pendulum
now and 10 minutes from now the physics
wouldn't change and so we know that
there's a time symmetry and so in this
case we would say oh uh there's a time
symmetry and then another theorem would
tell us oh energy is conserved so in
this case energy is a mixture of the
kinetic energy which is how much
movement there is and more movement the
more energy and potential energy which
in this case is because of gravity uh so
a combination of this must be conserved
we don't know exactly how uh which
formula and that's what we're going to
automatically discover
i see
and the the original approach i think
would just be that here this arrow i
parameterize this with some neural
network right i just say you know here i
plug a neural network i predict the next
time step and the next time step and the
next time step and that
it will maybe work right but it will
let's say we'll only implicitly make use
it will not actually make use of the
fact that something is conserved exactly
so you you go ahead and you say since
this is a dynamical system we know more
about the system we can impose
additional constraints and the
additional constraints right here if i
see this correctly essentially at every
time step you say
i want to build a neural network that's
always going to be the same neural
network that takes a state let's say the
pendulum in this state and predicts a
quantity let's call that
no g is the name of the network let's
call the quantity i don't know alpha
and i want to use that same neural
network in all the different states that
i find this thing in
and it always needs to predict the same
thing right since since it needs to uh
figure out a quantity that is conserved
exactly
and
now it is it is
if i just train a neural network to
always predict the same number right
here i would just end up with a neural
network that is predicting some some
kind of a constant right
so
your method
figures out how do i need to build
first of all this predictive neural
network to predict this conserved
quantity
such that
it actually predicts something useful
but then also how do i make this network
right here actually use the fact
that this other network predicts common
quantities right yeah exactly exactly so
that's why the name that the the word
useful in our title because there is
many conserved quantities that are kind
of not useful uh and so we want to find
those that are uh helpful for uh
loss final laws so in machine learning
we usually care about some performance
uh whatever it is uh and so
that's exactly what we that our
objective just cares about that and the
useful quantities are just
a proxy an intermediate uh thing uh for
getting us to better performance
yeah and so here you have you have this
main diagram i think that that would be
considered the main diagram describing
your method and this is on a task that
is a video prediction task and it's
about sliding
something down an incline could you may
maybe describe what the task here is
it's yes the frames are a bit a bit
lower resolution
so this is the physics 101 data set um
from josh tenenbaum's group i think
jesuit was the first author and they
have a collection of videos and in this
case it's a they have a hand dropping an
object passively like it just lets it
drop down and the object falls down and
there's a second object at the end of
the ramp they collide and then uh the
other one sometimes depending on the
masses and the friction and whatnot uh
the dynamics are kind of can change
that's the data set
and does so that there are multiple
videos yes and it's always different
objects or
like some objects could be
common between uh videos but there's
lots of objects so uh it's not always
the same object and that's kind of the
point the fact that it can vary um so
one
nice thing about the in other networks
is that um they can deal with uh with
raw video so some usually conserved
quantities
uh you get them from kind of state data
like when i was telling when we were
talking about the pendulum it's kind of
you have the exact position of the
pendulum you have the momentum of the
pendulum you don't have a pixel video of
the pendulum
and here because we deal with neural
networks that predict the concept
quantities um you can you can hopefully
uh get control quantities from video
yeah
so here the
the diagram shows a little bit of of
what your
what you
um are trying to do but also what you're
trying to avoid so the bottom path right
here if i see this correctly that would
be if i did nothing else except the
bottom path i would build this neural
network to just predict sort of the the
the future time steps and that often
turns out
poorly
i don't know this is a quite a pixel-ish
um mess but
it's sort of it's sort of all of a
sudden there are like three objects
instead of two and the the one is the
one is kind of gone or split up yeah and
it's a it's a bit of a
a mess and you attribute this to the
fact that it's just a video prediction
or yeah well in this case um to analyze
it and and to make the problem
challenging uh we made the like there
was very few data um in general
you can um
it's all like
symmetries and and inductive devices are
going to be most useful when uh the the
problem is hard and then there is like
less data so in this case there was a
few amounts of videos uh and also
because video prediction is pretty long
uh so at the very few like at the
beginning of the frames unlike the first
few frames there was not that much
mistakes but when you go very far into
the future then it's it's much harder um
so yeah those two problems lack of data
and the fact that you go a lot into the
future your method is and you also have
an algorithm described somewhere it's a
bit of a it's a it's a algorithm that is
oh right here it's an algorithm that has
multiple steps in it and one special
part is that you have this sort of inner
optimization loop right here now
i want to maybe go back to the diagram
and let's go let's walk through it once
before we before we you know take a look
at the formulas and all we can walk
through it once so the first thing that
happens if i understand correctly is you
take your first input and you do exactly
what we just said you run it through a
forward prediction neural network that
just tries to predict the future um
just plain by itself yeah right
so this has this has a bit of a of a
default thing but now you try to improve
that and this is all this is the entire
thing we're describing right now that is
one forward pass through your system so
if you would take every single
prediction that you made and you would
feed it through this g network right
here and this g network is you call it
an embedding network that is the thing
ultimately that's trying to predict a
conserved quantity
but it's not it's not necessarily just
outputting one number it's outputting an
entire vector
yeah so it's an outputting and embedding
vector and
the the goal obviously is that for all
of these inputs it should output the
same embedding vector
exactly exactly
but so ah so but this is this is going
to be let's say
trained such that across the data set
it works well so maybe you know for this
video sequence is going to predict
approximately the vector a for all the
frames if it works well and for another
sequence with two different objects that
obviously have a different total energy
or so it might predict a different
embedding vector
exactly but all the same across the
across the video sequence okay so this
is how we can imagine you train this g
network to sort of predict
whatever is
special about this particular data point
but inside of the data point conserved
among all the frames exactly because if
it was the same a for everyone then you
would wrap the issue that you mentioned
at the beginning then it's a useless
conserved quantity yeah yeah so it's
it's almost like a bit of a description
of the scene as such right that makes
the video predictors life easier if you
have sort of this this global
description
yeah yeah so the intuition i think is
let's think about when the if if the
network g was very good at predicting
the conserved quantities and perfectly
told you oh these five quantities i know
for certain that they're going to be
conserved then uh
we could uh we will see the next step uh
we haven't gone through it yet but the
intuition is that
knowing these five conserved quantities
is going to tell me a bit about what my
prediction should be
yeah and so it's kind of free
information that i i get to know
about constraints uh so it's kind of an
unsupervised loss that i have access at
this time yeah um it restricts it
restricts what you can output right
because ideally the f network should
only output whatever the g network says
is is the same right if the f network
can only output things that the g
network will embed to the same place in
the embedding space or a similar place
yes there's
just to be 100 precise there is lots of
images that could make the network g
happy um because it only constrains like
a few dimensions
but it has to uh make the the network g
say oh this is approximately what you
had at the beginning yeah okay
and so that that comes in in the next
step so here what you do
um you use you take the input again and
you route it through this f network
again but now this f network doesn't is
not like a free form predictor but it
actually takes has somehow the notion of
of this information that the g network
output out of the initial sequence again
and you do this in a very special way in
that you actually take the parameters of
f and you update them on the fly yes uh
you update them on the so this is within
a forward pass you actually update the
parameters
into the direction of the gradient of
g exactly
yes so yeah sorry this is i think that
that it takes it yeah so here
you have this neutral loss
yes exactly which do you maybe want to
talk about this briefly yes so about
another loss yeah sure so the another
loss essentially is telling you you
should have you should conserve g um so
um the you know for a fact that uh
um so there's two ways of conserving g
um they're roughly equivalent if you
fully impose them if you don't fully
impose them they're not equivalent
that's why we put the approximate sign
so let's look at the term a here um it's
basically saying oh you should conserve
g and so it should be all of them should
be equal to what g was telling you for
the input x naught
so if you make the embedding of your
prediction note that the x of t has kind
of a tilde on top of it so your
prediction for x t should uh have the
same construct quantities as your input
and that's what your term is and just an
msc over this uh neural embedding
the second one is very similar um
sometimes it's a a bit more useful more
stable because instead of if instead of
comparing to your in the very beginning
you compared to the previous time step
you have a more immediate signal and you
basically say you should conserve it uh
every time you apply f you should
conserve uh g
so that's another basically important
conservation
and now we update
theta and theta are the parameters of f
right theta are the parameters we have
we update these on the fly and i i i
suppose that we just do this you know in
the moment and for the next data point
we we go back to the sort of original
parameters yes uh and do this again so
this is sort of an on-the-fly update for
you know a temporary update of these
parameters into the direction
of this quantity right here so this is
the gradient of exactly the loss
that we just discussed with respect to
the parameters of f so essentially it
says
what parameters would make f
more apt at fulfilling this loss which
essentially means that these
which
how do we need to change f such that
these four word predictions make the g
conservation happier
exactly exactly so this is uh some
previous work of hours which we call
tailoring and the idea
of tailoring is just because of what you
said that the fact that the adaptation
is customized for each individual data
point uh and the idea there was a
general way of encoding inductive biases
uh with unsupervised auxiliary losses so
auxiliary losses in general you say for
instance one thing we could say is oh
why not we add energy conservation when
when we train sometimes auxiliary losses
would say okay i train for good
predictions and i train for energy
conservation at training time but if you
do that you're not going to enforce
energy conservation at test time um
because on the test then you're going to
have a generalization gap in energy
conservation but because yeah
energy uh conservation or any type of
conservation or any auxiliary loss can
be checked before making the prediction
a test time or a training time inside
the prediction function i can first make
my prediction and see okay uh do i like
it that does my equation loss does my
unsupervised loss like this prediction
and if not i can take a gradient step or
multiple grain steps to improve my
unsupervised loss in this case the
conservation loss and so this makes it
much better for the particular point
we care about which is the one we are
making a prediction for
um it's a bit surprising because it's a
single data point and maybe you have
trained with a million data points so
the question is why why does that one
data point matter if we train with one
million points well the idea is that
we you're training on the exact point
you care about so enforcing the
inductive bias in the exact point you
care about right now for which you're
making the prediction is going to uh
have a very big impact and so in this
case uh this green step
improves the prediction just for that
one point
yeah maybe it's it's also important to
highlight that the
the parameter here this theta that we
start with and also the parameters of g
those are the ones that will be learned
during the training procedure across the
entire training data set and then the
parameters here those are always
constructed in the moment data point by
data point to as you say tailor the
inductive bias and the inductive bias in
this case would sort of be this entire
term right here exactly essentially says
you know what do how do i need to change
my predictor in order to conserve
the particular thing that g decides is
the common quantity for this data point
yeah yeah
and
and this gives rise to
the the algorithm um so here is what we
just discussed this is the forward
forward prediction sequence with this
inner optimization step uh so we first
predict this
plane sequence then we temporarily
update the parameters and that allows us
to again do the forward pass but now
with the updated f function and that
gives us sort of our final predictions
and as you can see here during the
training
we
we sample always batches we forward
predict using this inner update and then
we take outer gradients and the l task
here that would just be that what you
call the task loss this would be the
video prediction loss or something like
this okay
so
my i have i have a lot of questions um
first of all this it seems it seems
quite
um
intricate right because if i think okay
these outer gradients right here
especially this gradient right here this
is how do i need to change theta now
okay how do i need to change theta this
depends on these predictions right here
these predictions right here have one
forward pass using theta then have a
gradient with respect to theta right
here inside of them right
and
and the all of those come from this
quantity which is already a forward pass
using theta right is is this
actually how it's implemented in
practice do you do stop gradient
somewhere do you have any hacks or
is this actually because it seems mighty
unstable right how does this actually
work as you specify
okay yeah that's a good question uh so
in general
it depends so if it was a single
prediction um so if it was like the
default sometimes we've applied this uh
kind of prediction time optimization uh
the tailoring procedure to regular tasks
like image classification and things
like this it's not that unstable because
you're just kind of doubling the
competition graph because you make one
prediction and then grading step and
then double that prediction so that's
fine
um now here you have two issues the fact
that you're taking the green step and
and the fact that you have many
predictions many uh predictions that
kind of build upon one upon the other
so that could get could get tricky um in
practice uh we've seen that if the
overall training regime uh is stable
then it works fine um but if the overall
thing is already unstable then it's it's
extremely tricky to to add things there
so for instance uh one thing we realized
was that
um because video prediction is very
expensive uh and and basically we
couldn't fit that many examples on a gpu
literally i think two or four um so um
we were initially using batch
normalization um and so uh that was
making the training the vanilla training
of the vanilla neural network so just f
already unstable um
and when we were adding our uh another
network improvement on top of it it
couldn't learn anything um yeah we'd
swap the badge normalization for layer
normalization then the vanilla training
was very very stable and then
suddenly the neural networks worked out
of the box um
and we think that that's because um
if the
grid of the or the original gradients
because of the bad normalization if you
compute the batch statistics with a very
small batch it's already very crazy and
unstable and then we couldn't learn when
the or the other thing is already stable
then it seems um for us it worked pretty
out of the box when we once we swapped
the later organization
okay that sounds good yeah i would i
would expect so um yeah yeah so for
instance i i would expect for instance
if we were to um
do a hundred steps or or many more steps
or um
for instance we were discussing before
how there were two losses um that
sometimes we tried one or the other um
the reason we came up with the second
loss that conserves kind of the
construct quantity between this time
step and the next time step was when we
were using batch normalization we were
wondering oh is is our another network
unstable or yeah and then we realized
okay no it's that it's the vanilla that
was unstable but uh that was part of our
concern because uh there is some papers
that mentioned that when there is a when
you're back propagating through a very
deep
graph
then the gradients are sometimes not
very informative
in our case we found that when the thing
is pretty stable
seems to work fine
but i could expect that if you make very
very long predictions or uh your thing
is already unstable then um
it only adds to the instability taking
the second order yeah
yeah and another thing that struck me is
that there is only right there's only
one gradient step here
um you you take one gradient step and
i'm going to
um
that that might also be something where
stability or computational graph size
first of all you just do a gradient step
many things would be possible right you
could do add an add a grad step you
could do an atom step you could do a
line search or a newton step or anything
like this but you have chosen to do like
the most simple thing which is a single
gradient step right i think you think
the the key word here is what you said
about simple uh we could have done
anything else but the the i think
simplicity is is a something to
um value a lot in research i feel and so
um we went for the simplest thing um
yeah and so one grain step and if you
can train with three green steps uh and
we've sometimes done that um it it's a
bit better because uh
you it this allows you to take smaller
grain steps uh and then sometimes you
optimize the inner loss uh further
better but uh in terms of one simplicity
if it works with one um
it's better
and two especially when you present the
algorithm in a paper you really want to
show the the simplest version and then
usually people now know that okay if you
can take one grain step you cannot
usually take more than one grain step
and it will just make the competition
graph larger but that's fine uh so we
were striving for simplicity both when
we were implementing and then when we
were showing the gallon
and you do have experiments that show
that even though you learn with one
gradient step and that is down here
somewhere even though you learn with one
gradient step you can in fact at
inference time then perform more than
one gradient step and that up to a
sizeable amount of steps like up to 100
steps or so here will actually improve
the outer loss right yes yes uh we think
that
essentially um
the another loss is kind of a projection
loss right because you you keep saying
okay why don't you make g happier and
happier and um
especially in the theory section we go a
bit about this but essentially um there
is many uh futures you could have
predicted and some of them make g
higher
imagine it's only one quantity for now
some of them will make g higher some of
them will make g lower and
uh when you force to conserve g all
these features say okay no you should
conserve g and therefore it's kind of
projecting one dimension and so um in
particular for conserved quantities
applying the same laws over and over uh
it's kind of stable because uh it you
will just keep going closer to these uh
manifold of predictions that conserve g
yeah
so there's no
no let's say danger of over overdoing i
mean there's a little bit but it as i
said it hits after like 100 steps
which is quite a bit right given that
you train with one
yes uh so eventually especially because
also these are neural networks so um
it's not like it's uh for instance if
when the we've tried with this with um
with hard-coded losses in in the
previous tailoring paper and it's the
true conserved quantity and the energy
is truly conserved then you can freely
uh do that and it will keep going down
but because it's a neural network then
suddenly i think you've tr you're going
uh outside it's kind of a distribution
you train g to be useful for one or two
or three green steps now you're using it
for a hundred it doesn't make you any
promises um yeah that makes sense
now so i i wanted to also come back a
little bit to a more conceptual idea
maybe this is you know this is
also a bit of a question about tailoring
in general what what you do here that
you essentially adjust the uh the
parameters of your forward predictor on
the fly there are many ways you could
have combined the two networks right the
one network that essentially predicts
the conserved quantity and the other one
that forward predicts for example you
could have optimized the predictions
themselves at runtime yes to make both
of them happy you could have um
i don't know you could have
just learned it as as one thing and not
even bothered with runtime optimization
why did you choose this why did you
choose this tailoring approach in
particular it seems it seems a bit
cumbersome right and it's not not maybe
the first choice one would come up with
what are the advantages here so there's
two
things uh in in in your question let me
answer one after the other so there is
one why the prediction time procedure
the runtime procedure and then the other
one is why adapt theta instead of x so
let me start why uh the runtime
procedure uh it goes back to what we
were talking a bit like 10 minutes ago
or so
the fact that
the alternative to tailoring is
obviously losses which are you you could
say okay
we are going to learn an auxiliary loss
that is going to be helpful for the
final prediction um so there is two
points here that uh i think could be
improved um the first one is we are
trying to learn an inductive bias so
for instance one very cool thing about
hamiltonian neural networks or cnns or
transformers is that the
inductive bias that they encode into the
network applies a training time but also
applies the test time so you know that
you have equivalence at this time uh and
and you you know that your prediction
satisfied is inductive bias and so
auditory losses if you train for energy
conservation or whatever loss you want
do not enforce do not satisfy inductive
bias and so for it to be a proper
inductive bias it has to be satisfied
also a test them and that's why we
optimize it at runtime
you also have to optimize it at the
training time because if you optimize it
only at testing then you have a
distribution
so that's why it has to be optimized
inside the prediction function so that's
the first reason why to there to be a
proper inductive bias it has to be
optimized uh
at runtime
the second question uh was oh sorry and
there's a second reason why we also do
that instead of actually losses and the
reason is that there is a very immediate
signal so imagine you encode energy
conservation
at training time um then it's a very um
loose signal uh to the final test
prediction because you're saying okay
this is going to affect my final
training parameters and then i'm going
to use my training parameters on a
validation set and this is going to lead
me to uh good predictions but this is
only happens you only can look at the
effect at the very end of training and
then you're going to use that on
validation and so
you could do that and i think there's
papers that do that using implicit
gradients
but the signal is much much
more cumbersome
instead if you use if you say okay no uh
the way i'm optimizing this is inside
the prediction function then you can
literally compute the grain the the
computation graph and optimize it into
it so that's the reason why we do that
at runtime
okay second point in your question was
why theta and not x
um and that's a great question as well
on that we experimentally found it a
very impactful uh like very stark
difference between both options in in
the previous in the tailoring paper
and and we have a
we think we understand why the intuition
is optimizing x actually helps uh
experimentally it makes sense that it
helps and
it also empirically found that it helps
but it helps very little um the reason
being that you can
it may find like an adversarial example
on that optimizes g perfectly and makes
g very happy with very small changes if
you optimize theta instead theta
has kind of the geometry of of the task
it knows the ways that uh it uh
the ways to change the output condition
on the input that uh kind of still do
not um deviate too much from what it has
learned so theta captures the dynamics
and says okay
i probably got it a bit wrong because
i'm not conserving g uh so but but i
don't want to deviate too much from what
i've learned so optimizing theta
still make sure that you satisfied what
you've learned so far and then it leads
to much much larger uh improvement yes
i mean it does bring up like just right
now it does it does seem like
might be possible to to set up some
adversarial setting right here where you
could maybe use g as sort of a
discriminator not optimizing x directly
but sort of optimizing the the
parameters of f in in maybe more of an
adversarial setting so not directly
taking a gradient step with respect to
the loss but maybe saying you know is
the is according to what g outputs is
this a real sample or is it a sample
that i have predicted
um is this
anything on your radar or yeah yeah i
think it's it's i think there's
something like what you said that that
that's going to be uh there uh in
particular i i think it just has a
feeling like uh
like this adversarial discriminator
because it's telling you oh if you're
not satisfying g conservation yeah then
most likely you are wrong especially if
you don't satisfy it by a large amount
because again they're approximately
conserved so um that's one um so one
thing i'm
interested in uh going forward and and i
think that that could be a avenue of
many future works is that we focused a
lot on when we're trying to make
predictions on kind of generative uh
networks the fact that you're sorry
generative not in the sense of
self-supervised learning but yeah but
more in like you predict the next input
given the the
sorry the the output given the input you
have to generate the the thing g is like
a checking network and checking
sometimes is easier right you just have
to say
stand back and say okay i like it i
don't like it and that may be much
easier to do and also the type of
network that you have that you're
building may be very different
architecturally maybe in the type of
network that we want to
encode and construct maybe
architecturally different from from the
f networks uh and maybe combining these
um proposal networks with these uh
checking networks uh may make different
architecture classes that could be
useful
yeah i wanted to get a little bit more
into
so you have you have experimental
results where you compare to various
baselines like you know without um and
and obviously obviously you're better
than them which is what we've come to
expect from machine learning papers
i want to i want to focus a little bit
on also here you have an investigation
into what the
the conservation what the embedding
network this g network actually looks at
do you maybe want to comment on this a
little bit and why this makes you
a little like why this makes you
comfortable saying like comparing this
to conserving quantities and and why
your assumptions might be correct yeah
yeah so um
we we were able to check the the fact
that we were learning construct
quantities uh in two ways one the
symbolic experiment uh on the physics
based we were able to recover energies
but in the video it's very hard to know
are you learning anything meaningful um
and so
we we were able okay let's let's inspect
what the g network is looking at uh one
thing here just to be precise is that um
we have to it's a dynamical system so we
have to have some notion of velocity so
g was actually taking two consecutive
frames uh to be able to have any chance
of of visualizing the velocity but here
okay we only look at one of the frames
and we say okay where is it looking at
and if it's not looking at this
reasonable stuff then maybe it's not
doing anything
and so um if you look at the another
loss it's an msc of um
of multiple dimensions in our case we
tried
that hyperparameter didn't really matter
for like
experimentally we'll we'll i'll come
back to this a bit later um but let's
say we fixed it to 64. so it was
predicting 64 numbers but you can if you
think about it you can kind of rotate
and exchange the dimensions and whatnot
so really what matters only is the pca
of this so you can take the pca and look
at what's the most important um
dimensions and then and then kind of
at the least important um and we found
that even though we were trying to
conserve 64 different numbers and in
practice they were like only four to six
that mattered uh and in particular the
first one mattered a lot uh like 80 four
percent of the variance was captured by
the first dimension so it's the one on
the left and uh it was comfortable like
comforting to see that uh this dimension
was looking at the right stuff so in
particular it looks primarily at the
object that's falling down you can see
it in red
and then
we also saw that it was often looking at
the edge uh we think that this is
because there were two types of here
they're both right to left but they were
sometimes sequences that the object was
falling left to right so uh we think
that the edge of the ramp was a good
signal on measuring this and it also
looks very faintly but it also looks a
bit at the object uh waiting to be hit
um yeah
so that was very comforting to see so
you can see for instance other
dimensions um that were much less
important than the first one uh they are
not very meaningful at all and then the
fourth one and the sixth one do have
some some meaning um we think that the
fourth one was caring more about orange
type stuff and we think that maybe it's
because of there was sometimes a hand
that was going on there we don't know
and the sixth one we we found that was
following uh blue objects very closely
so here of course we only show uh one
example over time
so this is the time sequence as we track
the object on the appendix we show that
there it basically didn't matter the
example didn't matter it reproduced very
nicely and that also gave us confidence
that the g network was learning
something meaningful
cool um
so i have
this this question you you have a lot of
these physics examples right which also
comes close to your your notion of you
know in physical systems in dynamical
systems there are these conserved
quantities and so on
is it is it fair to say that probably in
most video prediction tasks unless it's
like i don't know a spongebob video
where every four seconds there is a like
a cut like in most video prediction
tasks i can reasonably say if a model
just observes the pixel information then
probably it's going to find some of
these con conserved things it's almost
like a prior on
you know stuff over time moves
slowly and in according to
physical reality or something like this
yeah yeah exactly i think there's uh
probably some type of prior uh like this
that uh enforcing the fact that some
things are approximately conserved uh is
going to be useful beyond uh physics we
it's true that we've uh because of the
motivation especially we thought that
that's the most likely thing to work and
also the message was clear
but we think that possibly in other
types of videos like well even like many
videos are essentially
everything is physics if you're in the
real world uh
like cars or people moving around yeah
but but they also like they also have
some intrinsic
movement that doesn't follow passive
physics laws but um there's always do
you have to have like something in mind
like accept accept cuts between you know
scenes
you'll get goodbye yeah
do do do you have do you have anything
other in is there like a prominent
example where this type of model would
would fail
fail um
so
i think
um
i mean i was thinking maybe
one one easy example of something that
would fail is you have a video and
you uh
often have things that enter the video
that were not in the video yeah
then here you get into trouble because
there's a something that was not
observed it's the same thing that we
were talking energy dissipation before
if you
consider the entire system then maybe
there's something that's going to get
controversy you consider heat and
whatnot yeah but anything that you
cannot observe then enforces some things
that are not getting concerned um so
yeah extra objects um
that appear and disappear then uh you're
going to get into trouble yeah i was
think i was like going to mention the
exact same thing and i mean it's still
going to be the case that the g network
you know it can it can just output
something like well
the energy of the entire universe is
still the same right but that then
ceases to be useful
yes yes exactly so yeah things and one
other thing i think conversely it could
be that
there is a lot of work that will need to
be done if the camera is uh
is uh moving a lot um because then all
of these objects
will for sure appear that we're not
there because you're looking at stuff
that was not there uh so if you look at
the videos this video is static uh the
camera's not sorry the scene is not
static but so uh most likely some work
will need to be done in this case one
good thing about this is that we're not
fully imposing the conservation uh so
some approximately actually the fact
that it's approximate allows us to
handle things that were not previously
possible before but uh still you will
get into trouble if you keep entering
stuff
but it's i mean just just out of
intuition it seems more likely that the
network detects something like you know
there's there's a blue bunch of pixels
and and uh an orange bunch of pixels and
these pixels sort of move together as
objects
rather than the network from video
somehow determining aha there's laws of
physics and there's gravity and there's
friction and there's sliding
the first situation seems a bit more
likely here right yes yes actually so
just
two for instance give a bit of context
of how we came up with this idea um
initially the the original tailoring
paper we initially came up with
applications on adversarial examples and
contrastive learning and we i had the
feeling that it could have be applied to
inductive devices but i was not fully
sure i didn't know exactly how and then
um
the
roster gave a talk at mit uh it's online
on the youtube ea seminar uh and it was
telling us how um
um it's very hard to encode induct
devices in neural networks and in their
case basically they were predicting how
a robot was pushing a bunch of carrot
and the carrot was moving around and
they trained it between the carrot
predictor uh and that it worked fine
very good prediction but then they used
it for planning a test time and suddenly
it was not conserving carrot it was
making carrot disappear instead of
bringing it to the proper place
uh and that and they were like okay that
neural networks don't work so we're
going to use a constraint linear model
and they were able to solve the problem
this way but i was like okay maybe maybe
we can actually if we enforced it inside
the prediction function it would
conserve carrot and and then that was
the motivation that
like let us
go into this direction
cool is there anything you else you want
to say about the the experimental
results we touched on sort of upping the
inner steps and the and the uh the grad
cam but is there anything you special
you want to say about sort of your your
tests on uh for example the pendulums or
yeah i think some of the
experiments uh it depends on how much
time we have but on the and the
pendulum there was a symbolic component
so the g doesn't have to be fully neural
yeah uh so in in the origin in the first
i think those are the first experiments
the g is kind of a program with some
parameter like a formula and there we
search over formulas uh because it's a
state information the pendulum that you
draw like the angle and the momentum and
there we search over formulas um and
then there's some parameters as well
that get trained over with green descent
yeah and there we saw that okay we we
are able to recover the true formulas of
the energy and it leads to better
prediction than vanilla mlp that does
not learn about conservations
and there also you can see that that
actually you can you can even handle
these approximate constraints where you
have real data which then the networks
that have the hard-coded constraints
can't handle as well yeah exactly so
there is a cool paper uh hamiltonian
neural networks that
encodes i think that the graph is a bit
above i think um that basically the
yeah here one this one perfect so uh
it's it's a very cool paper um that
they construct the network in such a way
that it conserves energy and so it we
thought it was a very good comparison uh
because it improves a lot the uh above a
vanilla mlp that does not conserve
energy so if you look on the right uh
this is changing agent n conserved
quantity which is what they believe is
they predict it's going to be something
the energy you can see the baseline
neural network which is just the
df basically just f uh quickly loses
energy and therefore this is going to
lead to much worse predictions on the
left you can see the msc goes up um if
you fully impose energy well this is a
much better
inductive bias the fact that energy is
constricted and you can see that uh the
predictions are much better um but if
you only softly encode it then we show
that we can do much better
and then we compare to actually knowing
the the loss um the the formula for the
energy and we see that essentially the
performance is pretty much the same we
are able to discover it and then use it
to softly encode energy conservation
nice seems like seems like a good deal
i mean it's it's it's it's really cool
that if you know something about your
problem this is sort of another way that
you can directly encode that even in in
sort of a soft way i think this the
softness is something super useful
especially in the real world right
compared to sort of the the really hard
constraints that often these these
asymmetry conserving neural networks
have
yeah yeah
cool yeah i think this is about it for
for this paper is there anything you
want to uh you have a theoretical
section we didn't talk much about the
symbolic regression but i think we've
gotten sort of to to the essence is
there anything else you want to
uh add to this or or anything people
should know that your code is online
right put this online so it can be
easily beat up one um it's uh on with
pytorch um but uh i think actually jugs
will make it these type of things of a
parameter a kind of this tailoring
process that essentially have a
parameter per example uh with jugs are
very it's it's very very easy to to
encode and parallelize so that will also
make it easier but with pythort it's
already pretty easy to the with pytorch
higher uh it's very easy to implement so
i think that should be
easy to build up i just wanted to point
out that this was a group effort so in
particular dylan douglar
was also uh first aqua first author in
this work and did a lot of the
experiments and then um we also had alan
cho and chelsea finn uh from stanford uh
collaborating on this work because we
found they had a really cool paper on
learning discrete synergies um at the
learning symmetries uh by
reparameterization
and then uh we also had professor josh
silenbaum from mit cognitive science and
kenji kawaguchi from the university of
singapore
cool excellent well feron thank you so
much for being here with us uh today and
and all the all the best i hope you have
great great ideas in the future thank
you